SPEAKER: In this
Cloud Minute, you'll
learn how to quickly deploy a
Java Web Application to Google
App Engine Standard with Maven.
First, add the
App Engine plug-in
to [? pump.xml. ?] Then, create
an app engine web.xml file
and specify Java 8 as
the App Engine run type.
App Engine [? extender ?]
now supports servlet 3.1,
so you can annotate
your servlets.
You can also use all of the
Java 8 API's end features,
such as string and lambdas.
Finally, deploy the
application using Maven.
Once deployed, you can
access the application
with the project's URL on
[? appspa.com. ?] You can also
deploy this application
directly from Gradle, IntelliJ,
or Eclipse using
respective plug-ins.
Learn more on the
Google Cloud Platform
for Java developer's website.